.
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
AMERICA, WE HOPE YOU ARE READY
FOR A BRAND-NEW KAMALA.
THE VEEP IS READY TO MOVE PAST
NUMEROUS SETBACKS, A MASSIVE
STAFF EXODUS AND CRINGE-WORTHY
SPEECHES LIKE THIS.
>> THINK OF THIS MOMENT AS A
MOMENT THAT IS ABOUT GREAT
MOMENTUM.
YOU NEED TO GET TO GO.
NEED TO BE ABLE TO GET WERE YOU
NEED TO GO TO DO THE WORK AND
GET HOME.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE CHILDREN
OF THE COMMUNITY, THEY ARE THE
CHILDREN OF THE COMMUNITY.
>> THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THE
PASSAGE OF TIME.
SO WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT,
THERE'S GREAT SIGNIFICANCE TO
THE PASSAGE OF TIME.
>> YOU'RE GOING TO LITERALLY SEE
THE CRATERS ON THE MOON WITH
YOUR OWN EYES.
WITH YOUR OWN EYES.
>> Jeanine: A NEW REPORT CLAIMS
THE VICE PRESIDENT IS IN A
BETTER PLACE AFTER THE MIDTERM
RESULTS AND READY TO HIT THE
ROAD TO SHOW OFF THE NEW AND
IMPROVED VERSION OF HERSELF.
ONE FORMER HARRIS AIDE SAYING,
QUOTE, NOW THAT IT LOOKS LIKE
BIDEN'S RUNNING, SHE'S REALLY
BEING TREATED LIKE WHAT I WOULD
CALL A NORMAL VICE PRESIDENT.
THERE'S JUST LESS ATTENTION,
WHICH I THINK ACTUALLY FREES HER
UP TO FOCUS ON EXCELLING, AND
NOT HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THE
RELENTLESS SCRUTINY.
>> ONE WHITE HOUSE ALLY CLAIMS
KAMALA IS JUST MISUNDERSTOOD.
QUOTE, ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT THIS ADMINISTRATION HAD IS
I DON'T THINK THAT THE WHITE
HOUSE WRIT LARGE FULLY
UNDERSTOOD WHAT IT MEANT TO HAVE
A HISTORIC VICE PRESIDENT.
YOU HAVE TO PUT HER OUT MORE ON
SOME THINGS, BECAUSE IT LOOKS
DIFFERENT, AND IT IS DIFFERENT,
RIGHT?
KAMALA IS ALREADY MAKING
PROGRESS BY LITERALLY STANDING
UP TO BIDEN.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
>> Jeanine: OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
SO, UMM, I'LL ASK YOU THIS,
GREG, THEY'RE SAYING THAT LESS
ATTENTION ON HER NOW FREES
KAMALA UP TO EXCELLING.
>> Greg: HMM.
>> Jeanine: IS WHY IS THERE LESS
ATTENTION ON HER NOW BECAUSE JOE
IS RUNNING?
EXPLAIN THAT TO ME.
>> Greg: IT'S A MARVELOUS
COINCIDENCE.
AS THE MEDIA AND DEMOCRATS ARE
GENTLY TRYING TO PRY THE CAR
KEYS FROM OLD JOE, THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT WHAT A GREAT
IMPROVED DRIVER KAMALA IS.
MAYBE THIS IS A SLIGHT PUSH,
PUSHING HER BACK IN THE
SPOTLIGHT.
SHE SAYS SHE'S IN A BETTER
PLACE.
A BETTER PLACE THAN WHERE?
I DON'T KNOW WHERE SHE IS.
AMELIA EARHART AS A BIGGER
FOOTPRINT THAN HER.
THEY SHRUNK HER SO YOU CAN'T
TALK ABOUT HER ANYMORE.
I'M RUNNING OUT OF THINGS TO
SAY.
SHE'S ONE STEP ABOVE THE LADIES
THAT ON THE BRIEFCASES ON "DEAL
OR NO DEAL."
BUT IT'S NOT HER FAULT.
THIS IS WHERE I DEFEND HER,
BECAUSE SHE'S A GREAT AMERICAN.
IT'S NOT HER FAULT IN THIS
HIRING PHASE.
IT WASN'T LIKE THEY WERE LOOKING
FOR COMPETENCE OR STRESSING
CAPABILITIES TO THAT PERSON'S
POINT, WHOEVER SAID THAT, IT WAS
ALL ABOUT THE HISTORIC FIRST.
HISTORIC FIRST NOW IS AN
OBSESSION EVERY TIME THE DEMS
ARE IN POWER, BECAUSE THEY USE
IT AGAINST REPUBLICANS.
YOU MUST BE A RACIST, A BIGOT OF
SOME KIND.
THEN YOU LOOK AT ALL OF THE --
FEELS LIKE I'VE THIS BEFORE, BUT
THAT STOP ME -- THE LOOK OF
HISTORICAL FIRSTS ARE ALSO
HISTORICAL FIRSTS.
RACHEL LAVINE, KAMALA, LORI
LIGHTFOOT, PETE BUTTIGIEG.
IT'S EFFECTIVE.
THE HISTORICAL FIRST IS
EFFECTIVE IN GETTING THE PERSON
IN, BUT LOUSY AT GETTING THE
RIGHT PERSON IN.
DOES THAT HELP?
I HOPE SO.
>> Jeanine: NO.
BUT THANK YOU.
NO.
THANK YOU.
>> Greg: NO.
>> Jeanine: ALL RIGHT.
LET ME ASK YOU, HAROLD, BECAUSE
YOU'RE A REASONABLE -- HANNITY
IT'S GOOD TO BE BACK.
>> Jeanine: SHE SAYS THE
PRESSURE IS NOT ON HER ANYMORE,
BECAUSE SHE DOESN'T HAVE TO PUT
IN THE VOTE WHEN THE SENATE IS
TIED.
WHAT ELSE IS SHE DOING?
HAROLD: SHE WAS ELECTED WITH THE
VICE PRESIDENT.
SHE NEEDS A RESET.
THE PRESIDENT AND THE COUNTRY
COULD USE HER BEING A MORE
RELIABLE AND EFFECTIVE PARTNER
FOR THE PRESIDENT.
I'VE URGED ON THIS SHOW MANY,
MANY TIMES, IF SHE TACKLED
BORDER SECURITY, LAYING OUT
ELEMENTS ON THE SHOWS, IT WOULD
GO A LONG WAY TOWARD HELPING NOT
ONLY PRESIDENT BIDEN BUT THE
COUNTRY.
SECOND, SHE HAS MORE EXPERIENCE
THAN ANYBODY IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION TO DEAL WITH
CRIME.
SHE WAS A DA.
SHE WAS AN AG OF THE BIGGEST AND
MOST POPULACE STATE IN THE
COUNTRY.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF SHE WENT
AROUND THE COUNTRY COLLECTING
BEST PRACTICES IDEAS, THINGS
THAT ARE WORKING, POLICE
OFFICERS AND ACTING COMMUNITIES,
POLICE OFFICERS BEING FUNDED AND
DAs THAT --
>> Jeanine: WHY ISN'T SHE?
HAROLD: WHETHER PRESIDENT BIDEN
RUNS AGAIN IN TWO YEARS -- I
BELIEVE HE WILL.
THIS ISN'T TRYING TO BE COY WITH
WORDS.
IF HE DECIDES TO RUN, NOT
ELECTED OR RE-ELECTED, SHE'D RUN
IN FOUR MORE YEARS.
THIS IS THE TIME TO BUILD THAT
BODY OF WORK.
IF I WERE THEM, I'D STOP TALKING
AND START DOING.
>> Jeanine: YOU'RE A WOMAN.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT HER, DANA?
>> Dana: UMM, I DON'T THINK OF
HER NECESSARILY AS A WOMAN.
I THINK OF HER AS A
DISAPPOINTMENT IN TERMS OF A
VICE PRESIDENT.
THERE WAS SOMETHING ABOUT THAT
HISTORICAL FIRST, OKAY, THIS IS
THE FIRST ONE, AND THEN SHE
BASICALLY WHIFFS ON EVERY POLICY
SHE'S BEEN GIVEN, INCLUDING THE
MOST IMPORTANT ONE, WHICH WAS
THE BORDER, AND SHE DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING FOR HER.
THAT'S NOT GOOD FOR HER.
WELL, NOT GOOD FOR THE COUNTRY
MOSTLY.
SHE'S HAVING A GREAT COUPLE OF
WEEKS.
WHO'S HAD A LAST WEEK?
PETE BUTTIGIEG.
SHE SAT BACK AND WATCHED THAT.
BIDEN IS ON THE HOOK FOR
DOCUMENTS.
WATCH CAREFULLY IF SHE RESPONDS
TO THAT.
DOES SHE THROW HIM A LIFELINE OR
A BRICK?
WE'LL SEE HOW THAT GOES.
THEY HAD 35 DIFFERENT STAFF
CHANGES FOR HER TO GET TO THIS
POINT.
SLIGHT EXAGGERATION, BUT NOT
MUCH.
HOWEVER MANY PEOPLE LEFT HER
CAMPAIGN.
THEN ON THE RECORD SAID WHY THEY
LEFT HER CAMPAIGN.
THE PEOPLE WHO LEFT THE WHITE
HOUSE STAFF OFFICE WERE ON THE
RECORD SAYING WHY THEY LEFT.
BECAUSE IT WAS CHAOTIC, SHE
WASN'T A LEADER, SHE WOULDN'T
LISTEN TO THEM.
MAYBE ALL OF A SUDDEN SHE HAS A
GREAT STAFF, AND THAT'S
WONDERFUL, BUT I HAVE TO WONDER
HOW IS IT THAT THE MEDIA, THE
EDITORS, KEEP WRITING THIS
STORY.
SHE'S ALWAYS ON THE CUSP OF
SHOWING US HOW GREAT SHE IS.
I'LL SIT HERE AND WAIT TO SEE
THAT.
BEING IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, IF YOU'RE THE
PRINCIPAL, YOU'RE NEVER
RESPONSIBLE.
IT'S ALWAYS THE STAFF FAILED YOU
OR SOMEBODY ELSE'S FAULT.
NOBODY TAKES PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR ANYTHING.
I'LL BELIEVE IT WHEN I SEE IT.
SHE WAS A TERRIBLE BOSS.
THAT'S WHAT HER STAFFERS SAY.
LET'S SEE IF SHE CAN BE A BETTER
VICE PRESIDENT WITH NEW STAFF.
>> Jeanine: WROTE JESSE, SHE WAS
CHARGED WITH BEING THE BORDER
CZAR.
I'VE NEVER SEEN A REPORT ON ROOT
CAUSES, BUT YESTERDAY NO, MAYOR
ADAMS SAID, TO HIS CREDIT, HE
SAID, WE NEED A NATIONAL BORDER
CZAR.
I THOUGHT TO MYSELF, HER OWN
PARTY DOESN'T KNOW WHAT HER JOB
IS.
>> Jesse: YEAH.
THAT'S EMBARRASSING.
IF I WAS BIDEN, I'D BE MAD.
THE WEEK THEY APPOINT A SPECIAL
COUNSEL TO INVESTIGATE YOU, THE
NEXT WEEK YOUR VP COMES OUT WITH
A PIECE THAT SAYS, YOU KNOW
WHAT, THINGS ARE GOING GREAT FOR
THE VICE PRESIDENT.
PERMISSION TO MAKE AN ANALOGY.
>> Jeanine: YES.
>> Jesse: THIS IS LIKE GREG
GUTFELD NEARLY DROWNING, AND THE
NEXT WEEK JESSE WATTERS PLACED A
PIECE IN POLITICO THAT SAID
PRIMETIME IS WALKING ON WATER.
IT WOULD BE IN POOR TASTE.
I READ THIS WHOLE PIECE.
IT'S YOUR TYPICAL GIRL POWER
PSYCHO BABBLE, HOW IS KAMALA
FEELING.
THE FIRST LINE OF IT IS NEW
YEAR, NEW YOU.
I'M IN A BETTER PLACE.
I DON'T LIKE ALL THE ATTENTION
I'M GETTING.
NOW SHE FEELS FREE TO BE NORMAL.
>> Dana: OH, JEEZ.
>> Jesse: DICK CHENEY WAS SHOT
IN THE FACE.
DID ANYONE WRITE A THOUSAND
WORDS ABOUT WHAT HE WAS FEELING?
WHATEVER.
SOMEBODY SHOT SOMEBODY IN THE
FACE.
HOW ABOUT THIS?
MIKE PENCE ALMOST GOT HUNG BY
HIS PRESIDENT ALLEGEDLY.
DID ANYBODY WRITE A THOUSAND
WORDS ABOUT HOW MIKE WAS
FEELING, OR HOW AL GORE --
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: MY POINT IS --
>> Greg: PERMISSION DENIED.
>> Jesse: NO.
PERMISSION WAS GRANTED.
HE FELL ON HIS FACE COMING OUT
OF THE APPLICANT.
LISTEN, SHE FEELS A SENSE OF
COMFORT, A SENSE OF FLEXIBILITY.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THAT
MEANS.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT IT MEANS TO BE
FREED UP?
FREED UP FROM WHAT?
>> Jeanine: RIGHT.
>> Jesse: THEY HAD A PIECE, A
PARAGRAPH, AFTER RETURNING FROM
HOLIDAY BREAK, KAMALA HARRIS SAT
HER STAFF DOWN AND WENT AROUND
THE TABLE AND ASKED EVERYBODY
WHAT THEIR WORD OF THE YEAR WAS.
HER WORD OF THE YEAR WAS
"MOMENTUM."
IMAGINE BUSH, VICE PRESIDENT IN
THE '80s FOR RONALD REAGAN,
SITTING HIS STAFF DOWN, "EXCUSE
ME, WHAT IS YOUR WORD OF THE
YEAR?"
THEY WERE FIGHTING COMMUNISM.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE TIME FOR STAFF
MEETINGS ABOUT THEIR WORD OF THE
YEAR.
COME ON.
NOW SHE'S SAYING SHE DOESN'T
CARE ABOUT POLITICS, SHE'S NOT
RUNNING, SHE'S GIGGLING AT MAYOR
PETE FOR BOTCHING THE AIRPLANES
BEING GROUNDED.
>> Dana: EXACTLY.
>> Jesse: SHE'S DONE.
I FEEL BAD FOR JOE BIDEN